kosovo has postponed the introduction of
tougher border controls with serbia
after the plan triggered riots and
police were shot at authorities have now
removed roadblocks put there by ethnic
serbs the riots started after the kosovo
government announced a decision that
would force people in majority ethnic
serb areas to swap their license plates
for kosovo issued ones
[Music]
sirens rang through the night as police
shut the barnyak and yerini border
crossings in northern kosovo
this came after serbian demonstrators
shot at authorities and blocked roads
close to the border crossings
they were angry about a new ruling from
the kosovan government that ethnic serbs
can no longer use serbian id cards in
kosovo
and car owners with registration plates
issued by serbia would have to change
them for kosovo license plates within
two months
the standoff left many people stuck at
border control
unable to get back home
we arrived here last night and the
police asked us where we were going we
told them we were going home the police
stopped us here because we cannot pass
the serbian president said his
government would preserve peace at any
cost but
if they dared to persecute serbs
mistreat serbs
kill serbs
serbia will win that's all i have to say
the kosovan government released a
statement maintaining that multiple
aggressive acts were perpetrated this
afternoon and evening instigated and
planned by belgrade authorities
tensions between the two countries are
now the worst they've been in
years kosovo declared independence from
serbia in 2008. serbia has refused to
recognize kosovo's statehood even though
it has no formal control there kosovo's
fragile piece is maintained by a nato
mission which has
3770 troops on the ground
nato's k4 said that they are prepared to
intervene if stability is jeopardized
they released a statement saying that
our nato-led k-4 mission is fully
focused on the daily implementation of
its u.n mandate to ensure a safe and
secure environment and freedom of
movement for all the people of kosovo
the kosovan government has agreed to
postpone the new rulings until september
1st as the ethnic serbs have removed the
barricades
soldiers from both sides continued to
patrol the border
following the unrest
let's get into this with rudy garassic
uh he's an editor for dw programs and an
expert on the western balkans he joins
us from the serbian capital belgrade uh
welcome rudiger so now the barricades
have come down and these new regulations
have been suspended but i guess this is
not the end of this problem
this is exactly how it look how it looks
like it has been postponed for 30 days
so we can expect the same thing to
happen in 30 days again unless there is
not any kind of solution in the meantime
and you've been speaking to people in in
belgrade what have they been telling you
about this latest flare-up
first of all everybody told me they
weren't afraid of any war and they
suppose it to be very unlikely that it
comes to an escalation but
then when talking a bit longer to the
people you notice that they are actually
afraid which is quite understandable
looking at the fact that there have has
been trouble in this area in the former
yugoslavia ever since 1991 there has
been no war since
1999 which was the nato bombing of
serbia and the
liberation if you want to put it like
this of crossover that used to be a
province of serbia before but there have
has been unrest at a regular basis ever
since then and people are a bit nervous
yes they are
right and it's it's easy to forget about
this especially the the war in ukraine
um uh uh going on that that there have
been
this simmering conflict between uh
serbia and kosovo for decades
true it has never come to a real
escalation uh actually a real escalation
is as well very unlikely as you already
mentioned there's almost 4 000 nato
troops standing in the area and all
countries but bosnia herzegovina in the
neighborhood are nato member countries
still people are looking at the
ukrainian conflict and they it reminds
them on the wars they had here the
former yugoslavia back in the 90s
right and as you say nato troops still
there
who or what are they protecting and how
effective are they
they are protecting peace in kosovo they
are protected in a euphoria mission
which is in the ant a nato mission as
well in bosnia the peace in bosnia and
the neighboring countries from albania
to croatia are all but bosnia and
herzegovina and serbia nato members so
they are protecting the aliens as such
right and if you look at the the wider
context
serbia is probably russia's closest ally
in europe
does any of this have a connection to
the war in ukraine
it certainly has in terms of that russia
has for years
used the western balkans as a hot stop
for troublemaking for making problems
for the international community or
disrupting the peace and
the processes leading to peace here uh
on the other hand the next russian
border is far away there are no russian
troops nearby and whether serbia is
really an ally of russia is a good
question serbia is completely dependent
economically on the european union the
russians in western investment here is
down to 1.7 so it's basically
not important and i think this is more
of a propaganda battle than anything
material
and you've got to wonder though given
all these given all these
tensions and given that russia is sort
of uh looking over everyone's shoulder
at this
why did kosovo choose this moment to
impose this when this was this this this
notion of changing the the driving
license or the license plates it seems
from the outside not a major issue
that's true
it is not a major issue for the people
living here either but it is a major
issue or for the koscium kosovo
government
because serbia has been treating kosovo
ever since the country became
independent or even longer in that
fashion so it's kind of understandable
that the prime minister albin kurti at a
certain point wants this to change and
he doesn't have to see any other means
to go into that direction
okay
thank you so much for joining us and
outlining that so clearly uh rudy
garothic in belgrade